well guys as I have done for the past
two years in a row every time the Super
Bowl happens there's some amazing
trailers that air for films that I'm
very pumped for that you guys have
pumped for and I always talk to you guys
about them every year and Here I am
doing it once again now a little teaser
spot aired for Captain America the
Winter Soldier which is when my most
anticipated movies of the rest of this
year however the full trailer is
available online and that's the trailer
i'm going to be reviewing its two and a
half minutes long and it looks
spectacular i'm telling you this trailer
blew me away this is in my opinion the
best superhero trailer I've seen since
that first theatrical trailer for The
Avengers this thing looks amazing the
action looks great the special effects
look really good a lot of the way that
it's film really intrigues me like there
was actually some shots in this trailer
that I was thinking to myself that
actually looks kind of dangerous to
obtain if I was the cameraman I'd be a
little bit worried but it looks really
great now we all knew it was gonna look
really good I mean it's a Marvel movie
there's lots of money behind this thing
it's a new superhero movie but how does
the story look I am consistently
intrigued by the way this film is
looking and I really like the direction
it seems to be taking from what I heard
from the beginning they're trying to
make a movie that is more spy espionage
related around this larger-than-life
superhero story if they can do that
successfully then they can have the same
success that the Dark Knight had where
it took a comic book film and it took it
extremely serious like it was a crime
story that's a great way to approach
this type of material and i love the
winter soldier story to how it's one of
his friends from the past and how that
can make it a lot harder on him i really
think there's a lot of really good drama
behind this story and i really hope this
film exploits it because it looks like
it's taking it more seriously no I know
not every superhero film has to take
things seriously you're supposed to have
fun with a lot of these movies and it
looks like it's having that as well
Falcon looks really cool Anthony Mackie
Robert Redford is looking great in there
he's gonna add some serious actor
credibility to this movie Nick Fury
actually getting his ass kicked in this
trailer no I like that because it takes
a character that has kind of been like
this invincible awesomely cool guy and
shows that he's human that's really cool
i love the way that winter soldier looks
i am really excited for this movie i was
blown away by this trailer i think it
looks fantastic
I am very pumped to see this movie what
did you guys think of the trailer let me
know below are you excited for it I'm
also going to be doing trailer reviews
for transformers 4 I wasn't originally
going to but then I started thinking
about it and I was like I have some
things to say I'm also going to be doing
a review for the amazing spider-man 2
the full three minute and 50 second
trailer that's online right now look
forward to that guys as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes